hello everyone I'm Daniel hours and I
make a wats I'm a white researcher at
MIT computer science and artificial
intelligence laboratory or Cecil and
also the director of Cecil and today I
will be moderating this panel on the
future completely so in this demo we
hope to explore with you some of our
latest insights in the challenges that
our researchers are traveling in the
field of computing we also will discuss
what the future of the digital landscape
might look like and how computer science
research will make a difference in how
we live work and play in the future I
will tell you more about Cecil in just a
minute first I would like to introduce
our panelists Tim berners-lee probably
needs no introduction that he invented
the world wide web 25 years ago in 1989
when he was
researcher at CERN which is the European
particle physics laboratory and today
tim is a crusader for a world wide web
that is appealing greater benefits to
humanity to easy access to information
and through providing more transparency
on how governments operate
and law was made by time magazine one of
the most influential people of the year
for his innovative approaches to
financial markets and who is an
economist by training he is a faculty
member at MIT Sloan School of Management
he directs the laboratory for non
financial engineering and is also
principal investigator
andrasta Drake can make robots that fly
like birds run like ostriches and these
lace is directing his innovative
approaches to create in robot parking
assistant search and rescue Russ finds
his inspiration in nature and today we
will tell you about what we might expect
from the field of robotics and from
robots not into the future
so I will share with your took a few
words about selling organization we all
want to play we will hear from the
panelists and at the end of their brief
speeches we will open the floor for
general questions and so first of all
detail we have over a hundred senior
researchers that needs not beautiful
investigators and we have over 100
students that mean full stops graduate
students and undergraduate researchers
and we are the largest interdisciplinary
research laboratory at MIT we were
founded 50 years ago as project map and
then since then our laboratory has paid
the plays a very important role in the
technological revolution starting with
the early days of time-sharing computers
and to the words of our data encryption
our objective is to teach our students
to become your old computer scientists
to be big thinkers and to become the
shop
not to take the field of computing to
the next level and also take on some of
the world's most pressing challenges our
researchers including robotics
researchers like myself as well as
experts in all fields of computing
security mobile wireless robotics
artificial intelligence databases theory
you name it we have experts in the field
and because of the staff diverse range
of interests we we are very excited and
very well equipped to take on
interdisciplinary challenges and
altogether imagine a world where
computing kangna turning the world into
a better place we imagine world where
physicians can use the most advanced
knowledge from genomics to engineer
better treatments that are improvised
for patients we imagine the world where
data can help
so make better decisions by predicting
the consequences of our decisions and
where the most recent advances in
encryption research for example
differential privacy until morning
encryption put people in charge of their
own data we also imagine a world where
the world's will be as common as
smartphones and cars and we ever watch
can do everything I'm helping with
search investing activities to holding
it wrong way which is my least favorite
you're at home so we really believe that
computing has a lot to offer in the way
our world that will be shaped in the
future and with this I would like to
stop and turn it over to Tim berners-lee
who will talk to us about the web we
want
thanks it's great to be here thank you
for having if you have a good pretty
Hannah she gets you identity let's see
so there are some seats over here but my
upcoming great to be here bet 50 packets
off by southwestern it's 25 years ago
that I would you only wrote a memo if I
was at the world wide web project and so
all the other all right so the the the
world maggots project I wrote a memo
about and when that was 25 years ago but
I probably said memo we should got leads
us to believe in front about
reorganizing information and for 50
years it was actually quite difficult to
persuade everybody okay good i hear
wouldn't be too complicated and that
they should give out their own
trading system to the opening a
psychological thing of getting open and
putting some of the things on the web
but there were people and got and just
like now when your garage post your kind
of stuff I suppose you can all people
with the truth in the right because they
get here I'll welcome a different and
then it here 25 years I asked what's the
way we want to step back very easy to
use with every moment somebody went
Barbra Jean needs it turns to live off
or other things happen on the web that
you realize that actually it's not just
like the air we breathe you actually
just step back and think about what this
be painted and think about whether it's
always going to be there and think about
the properties it's handled it well is
this car now we got to continue to
counter that are many threats to rights
on the web we talked about human rights
on the web that are you human rights to
establish like this tree where filters
work with you go groaning in the talk
about magnum cartridge 1215 you ask you
talk about your stellar rights if you're
brought up in South Africa that you
probably very proud of your new
constitution is put together with a very
good bill of rights you look awfully
still awake
the total extent we can trust among
those rights we have should exist on the
internet but in fact turns out the way
you go it turns out that some of the
things which you want to like the
ability to connect to anybody okay yeah
that's not no that's not really that is
called out because somebody continued
yes beginning in connectivity you could
get these people these connect to our
partners through our popular companies
but knowing say I know my email click to
any new pop star company not up I don't
want to just watch your movie time like
to personally visit anybody who started
making a little startup making a film
company in a song there are number of
countries we don't have poor putting
into the regulation of legislation ideas
about the internet being of right make
sure you can start something obviously
because you in you there are various
decorations people got out there the
dick declaration is that freedom is one
check them will check those out you can
sign them and there are the people
certainly might know
by Southwest back to move sign that ends
up bad that virtually freedom George so
what mean when we focus our rights upon
me internet well of course which we're
talking about such things your things
like express free expression that means
I can't won't be censored I will need to
be able to get to what I want and also
as a person I neathia put my stuff out
there so that anybody else can see it in
green country the web grew up as a non
national thing at important
international day international sounds
like nations get it together where do
our relative all nations it does in the
nervous lick it up and where you know
that the client server when you connect
your web browser web server they have
old cat they don't care about national
boundaries that has has a really sweet
side of exome way when international
community has grown up censorship blocks
really messes that up doesn't hurt
doesn't happen every country happens in
different areas means that you keep
track of that in the future were very
importantly where where it's happening
access just
to access the web right now as a firm
about now the lot of people who got that
connects us the web technically is
around 40 time so that it will read
further courting set and well it's
becoming more and more powerful and lots
of a little bit moon and the stuff on it
is more of a cool and it's bigger than
its more more empowering for people to
do their own medicine have the wrong man
later if you're in the video session
you'll be excited I'm excited about that
let's all try all these new things
you've done in that big more powerful
and makes a gap between the forty
percent do have a six percent the don't
have it even bigger obviously for people
don't many things get in the way
sometimes not sometimes poverty
sometimes it's illiteracy some obviously
our boots are for mobile and here in
sub-saharan Africa inverting countries
in general it is low below that will be
taking over critical things are the cost
of a gadget that can do wet and the cost
of the data plan yep betin enormous very
ultra-broadband of some sort or bad
something like we do Nina be part of the
young browser the website
society and he created it myself I wanna
be able I don't ever people just not
just a girl and she needs tenderly but
put together by everybody else he's get
on make it themselves in their own
language three see more and more stuff
so one of the properties of where is
that it's open that means lots of things
also means all sorts of things with
three people part of its open standards
obviously many you may work on building
web standards following me following the
latest versions of html5 / AP is so
keeping us up keeping the oil tea tree
really crucial Queen Bey's autopilot for
Switzerland CERN that physics that there
are 18 months united to persuade them to
actually provide a bottom of it said you
know up sir it's not going to charge
warranties for the web technology that
was a really crucial points update since
then there was a point of in the
consortium's history where we realize we
have to get all associate members who
are involved in what you say also you
know
done with respect we aren't very chatty
royalties if through people who have
been suffering from poverty not written
a book party a vocal sport is neutrality
for medium you can be your censorship is
when it's sort of block each other then
charity is that it's gonna be nothing
it's not just not being blocked or what
Harlan County near chances that you
don't measure it the ISPs for example
things one in Holland that slowed down
skype because they notice the skype
we're starting to eat into their
telephone revenue okay the Dutch return
to turn that around pretty quickly
interest legislation you can't do that
in America the convention is that
Internet service providers provide you
with connected to everyone and they
don't slow down packets go into their
commercial enemies but they're always
kind of such and as commercial pressure
to do so because they can make such a
min if they can actually go strangle
hold on viewers of consumer and just
connecting food next to so this is the
side of American pen Australians picture
of the happy item pocket underneath all
the people or all the demons trying to
get through you get up the workings of
these and use it summing it down to
there so that's very important many
things I think it you know it's
important for a commercial for an open
markets also important for democracy
it's important that you can go to any
physical size you like it's also hoped
in the nation that fact that you can't
build new website and very clean one one
person combined reprogram two people can
run this program they can send that
package through the cloud but linterna
the pilot will be using the cloud
diagram for is there on the whole cloud
mankind shall be a lock so right now
because you don't care what's inside it
you could just you command program she
can write a program they communicate and
they a new innovative protocol is born
new innovative system is running of the
web new social media mr. Burke spreading
across the web for example that's the
really want innovation so the pharmacy
the next 35 years and all this cost I
feel for coming here we know you have a
certain skill wheel where you have
certain streaming live the obvious that
moment this is the last year has been a
lot of focus on privacy it's a shame
that it took a sudden revelations to
cancel thinking about internet obviously
we have to think about to what extent we
give the agencies that are supposed to
protect us the ability to sample the
internet file me yet how I think we
really interesting question is how we
build a systems that will hold the
canceled checks and balances are
traditional and from Madisonian
government checks and balances weekly
dope like a little beat up before we
need very strong agencies candle to the
public who have the power to go in and
investigate the investigators and we
don't know how to build that yet when it
doesn't happen really important that we
can protest we've got our websites can
go as
she went black on yellow but we two
losers what we went back with we're
sober legislation is going to go through
also people went out into the streets
protesting sober in the u.s. protesting
actor in Europe to an agreement which
was going to give too much power to
copyright holders and nail and take away
freedom from individuals so this sort of
stuff it's important that it do that you
know the thoughts of things he had to be
able to protest about lots of things
were actually individual voices actually
added up so that this place this thing
is kept open and free those of you who
hear it last year we were we were
talking about erin's sources life and
how he was hopeful he was a huge part of
stopping trooper that's true doing
keep doing the things what would a I'll
do so those are some of the things which
item now that's on my agenda for the web
we want so there is a very mother lode
or web at 25 you can go to be bold
Littleton will be live on the chocolate
margins is a normal actually so God of
the web I want you all to think about
what sort of already want I want to not
just think about you when necessary to
take action make sure that by safe by
the end of the year we know what the
legislation of got neglected which
countries in all your classes works on
stretchers value input on the company
companies when necessary what sort of
theory that we want behind to where they
have for the next 25 25 years thank you
very much
turn it over to envelope go talk to us
about Big Data Big Brother and the
financial crisis and also while we get
the slide set up I want to start by
thanking Daniel larousse and my other
colleagues at csail and the organizers
of South by Southwest for inviting you
to participate in this great panel I
have to admit that as a financial
economist I feel a little bit out of
water and intimidated because I look at
the composition of the panel we've got
two of the leading roboticists of our
generation and the inventor of the
internet and nate so who ordered that
but you know when I told a friend of
mine that I was coming to South by
Southwest to be on this panel he was
very jealous and said why are you going
isn't South by Southwest all about
disruptive innovation and i have to say
that absolutely and financial economist
belong here because at least the first
half we've got down bananas has been
incredibly disruptive and so what I want
to talk about is what do we do about how
do we deal with the challenges of the
financial crisis and particularly big
data and the privacy issues that tin
mentioned so I'd like to start by
talking about what we know of the
economy and it turns out that there's
actually quite a lot that that we know
if we actually take a look at the data
that we have respect and pick this up
over the course of the last several
years the economy is been going up and
down but within the last few months it
looks like things are actually looking
pretty good so for example if you take a
look at you know recent announcements by
the bureau of economic analysis will
actually bring up the slides in just a
minute okay
yeah great so what do we know about the
economy well as I mentioned we've got a
lot of data coming in so we know this
inflation is about a tenth of a percent
unemployment six point six percent gdp
growth 2.4% non-farm payroll 113,000
housing foxygen hundred eighty thousand
the fed balance sheet is two point six
trillion all of these data tell us where
we are in the economy that basically
things are getting better but we still
got a ways to go however there's a huge
part of the economy that we actually
don't know much about for example hedge
funds and the shadow banking system that
was central in creating the financial
crisis what do we know about that well
let me show you the data that we've
collected about hedge funds and the
shadow banking sector this is what we
know now nothing and the reason we don't
know anything about it is because
there's actually no legal requirements
for hedge funds or the shadow banks to
report they're not even actually under
any regulatory jurisdiction and so the
old adage goes you can't manage what you
don't measure applies to this sector and
clearly we want to understand what these
data are telling us about that part of
the system but at the same time a lot of
these financial institutions have argued
well you know we're developing
proprietary trading strategies and
investments for our shareholders and if
you believe in private enterprise you
don't want to force us to disclose after
all you don't disclose coca-cola's
formula you want to give people at
set it to develop new innovations so the
question is is there some kind of
compromise between privacy and total
transparency and it's pretty clear that
there are certain things that have to be
kept private we don't want total
transparency the answer is yes there's
actually compromised and it has to do
with a new technology not so new to the
computer science literature but new in
its applications for finance and the
technology is known to secure
multi-party computation let me tell you
what it is with a simple example you
know I always wondered what the
socio-economic statuses of participants
at South by Southwest so one of the
things I'd like to know is what the
average salary is of people in this room
so let me start by asking anybody want
to tell me what their average salary is
and we can start computing an average
yeah not so much well we obviously
acknowledge that salaries quite
confidential thing so let me tell you
what my animals
so we can start trying to compute the
average in this room but I'm not going
to tell you what my salary is by itself
what I'm going to do is tell you what my
annual salary is plus a random number
that I choose and add to my salary so
the my salary plus the random number is
fifteen dollars so hopefully I've added
a negative number to my salad
so I'm happy to share that with you
fifteen dollars and I'm going to give
that number to somebody else in the
audience say Alice and i'm going to ask
alice to take that number fifteen
dollars and add to that her salary plus
her random number that own she goes and
she chooses and so Alice does that and
the sum is maybe thirty seven thousand
dollars and Alice takes that under and
gives it to somebody else who adds his
number and his salary and passes it
along to somebody else and somebody else
on something else until the last person
in the room Bob gets the number and Bob
adds to it his salary and his random
number and at that point the number
turns out to be 15 billion and Bob gives
it back to me I take that number fifteen
billion and i subtract from that my
random number I give it to Alice she
subtracts her rabbit number she passes
it and gives it to the next person
inclusive tracks her random number and
so on and so forth until Bob subtracts
his random number and at that point when
Bob subtracts his random number what Bob
has is the sum of everybody's salary
which when you divide by the total
number of people in the room which
everybody can see and public information
yields the actual salary of the average
in the room know where that anybody have
to reveal his or her salary but at the
end of the day we actually have the
average now of course this algorithm is
a pretty simple one in the sense that I
got together with Alice I could actually
cheat and figure out what Bob salary is
but there are more sophisticated
algorithms that allow no cheating to go
on and get permit us to calculate
numbers like average salaries or average
loan portfolios or average concentration
indexes and full swamps things that will
tell us what the systemic exposures are
the aggregate economy without
jeopardizing privacy so let me conclude
by pointing out that with the right
technology transparency and privacy can
both be achieved you don't have to give
it up as long as you have the
wherewithal and the right tools will be
able to deal with these kind of
challenges thank
next I will turn it over to us today
we'll ask why honey how they're coming
yeah hi there so it's sort of a cheesy
title the robot they're coming up and I
had to think a lot about whether I was
going to use their time a lot of healing
there's never been a time before where I
would have felt right using the title
and there may never be a time again
where I'll feel right using such a
cheesy title but but let me tell you why
there's robots are trending in such a
way right now just in a massive
proportion that this felt like the one
time where I could get away maybe using
the title and maybe it's not even
they're coming but they're actually here
and I want to make sure you guys know
the extent to which they are trending it
and it happened with a lot of progress
in active in academia and industry and
then it got quickly spurred on by this
massive relatively massive investment by
first by the government so there's a
national robotics initiative that
happened three years ago now where the
robotics community got together for
robotics caucus and the Congress made
robotics and national agenda and produce
research money for academic research in
robotics okay there's another thing huge
another 80 million dollars or so coming
from DARPA that was injected into
building robotic hardware in the US
you're just seeing many many more robots
moving around walking around in the
United States it's a worldwide
phenomenon there's all over the European
Union has massive funding for robotics
Japan and Korea and have been leaders in
robotics even at MIT where where we
spend we've been spending our precious
few junior
faculty squats filling in with
roboticist because we know that robotics
is hot it's half it's hot now ok Google
just just shocked the world in December
saying that they purchased eight of the
big robotics companies in the last six
months right so why did all this happen
why is all so much energy ok it's
because in the last five or six years
robots got awesome you must have seen
this before right so this is this is a
wildcat from Boston Dynamics this is a
UAVs but applying around you
individually doing amazing things but
collectively doing amazing sort of swarm
computation that's scale right that's at
the end upenn this is an airplane that
you know airplanes don't normally land
on a perch this airplane was developed
FC sale it can stall its wings and like
a bird and land on a perch like it like
a bird maybe it'll land on power lines
to trick the charge its batteries and
keep flying cred in fact it's so busted
now we have Joe just throwing airplanes
and wires all day long ok manipulation
capabilities in robots the hardware
technology that we've got now this is
from from Germany right this is a just
showcase of the robotic arm technology
that has matured there about a hand
technology able to do relatively
advanced manipulation past with glare
the sensing capabilities our robotics
has been just phenomenal progress this
is a kinect sensor than one of the John
Leonard's collegetown Whelan is walking
through is a perfect once with the
kinect Microsoft's Kinect sensor
primeSense sensor okay and after just a
single traversal the apartment look at
the kind of math keep the fallout right
then robots can see now they can't
necessarily understand what they're
seeing but they the geometric
representation of the world problem is
sort of gone away right robots can see
the environment and now robots are going
out and taking all these technologies
and putting them together and solving
our problems out in the real world one
of the ones that I've been involved in
last year is this project by the DARPA
competition by darka where we had to
field robots they didn't have the
humanoid robots to mute the humanoid
robot that had to go out and solve
handle a disaster response scenario so
this is a scene where they put us in
front of a debris pile had the clear
debris and get through to a magic door
in the debris okay but the point is we
didn't set this up and take one video
and put it on youtube this is a
challenge that had to work on game day
we had one shot with the real robot the
robot had a human operators that were to
connect it to the robot with a very
degraded network place so they are
allowed to give high-level commands
where they couldn't steer and control
the whole robot and I'll just show you a
really quick summary of the kind of
things we do i set it up so we could i
didn't use too much of my time but the
robots pretty amazingly capable in fact
this was this was a good thing for us
for the bipeds in the world we just had
this big competition in December
everybody said that the people who are
bringing bipedal robots are
all the robots are just going to fall
down and embarrass themselves but in
fact the robots been very well if I kept
it very well this guy happens to be so
wide but remember Hans and Franz in
center line the only way we can get
through the doors of sideways cost us
valuable time without was it this is
taking up with drill turning it on and
then you get a cut of shape out of the
wall and these are the knobs these are
things that had to work on competition
today to picking up up a fire hose and
mating it with a spigot we can do this
sort of in the wild now slowly and DARPA
put on this amazing event where we had
they've actually rented a NASCAR Stadium
the homesteads homestead speedway and we
had all the you know the 18 most
advanced humanoid robots in the world in
each of you to walk down pit crew late
and see all these humanoids and all the
most stressed out programmers in the
world work another robot four days
before and they put us through all this
to this to these competitions okay all
right so it's easy to say that and then
make you think that robotics is solved
but there's lots of things we can't do
yet right so the robots today we're
moving very not very gracefully very
slowly we want them to move like
ballerinas right I would be happy if our
Atlas robot our big humanoid had the
manipulation capability than a
two-year-old okay or a three-year-old
here to be able to maybe if i have a
factory where i am perfectly specified
objects maybe I'm okay which but if I
have unknown objects I haven't seen
before it's it's still a very hard
problems for object recognition seen
understanding high level decision making
these are all technical problems that
we're going to be tackling in the next
few years okay but there's the thing
problems with robotics to it I figure
than these these sort of one-off
research problems the thing that's going
to get robots out of the out of the
YouTube world and into the real world is
solving problems about robot themed to
spread they called on the great right
great depressing when you work that I
Robot a great great but there's new
fabrication technologies out there that
for instance Danielle is working on that
are making soft robots that will be able
to recover from this is one of
Danielle's videos of a earthworm robot
that she gets with a mallet all the
times and if we can figure out how to
not only build these things but control
these things to be as dexterous as as
the videos I've been showing you and
that can totally reshape the robotic
landscape ok our robots are too
expensive this is there was we spent
millions of dollars on that you provide
robotic saw and I want to send them out
into a world we're going to have to make
them much much cheaper and soft robotics
can help with that too they're using too
much energy the the humanoid robot
showed you actually the reason it had a
tether was because it's 15 kilowatts off
the wall when it's standing still right
so if you've seen the big dog robot
right so big dog has a 15 horsepower
motor and it's about an eighth of a
horse so I guess if you do the math it's
about a hundred times less efficient
than a horse okay we're going to have to
solve that we want to get them out
right we also have to get it make it
easier for people to work on robots out
in the field and give the legislation to
support this community in fossil the
environment ok but this is a good time
this is an amazing time for you to get
involved that you're thinking about a
robotic startup right there's never been
a better time where there's there's cops
sensors out there being an off-the-shelf
sensors actuators either robots the
robotics community has finally embraced
the open source movement both for
hardware and software that make their
movements as impact with robotics in a
major way you can download clamps or
entire humanoids now and get involved
right I then we just released the entire
planning and control infrastructure code
base for that humanoid robot I showed if
you're interested in using that you know
send me an email I will help you build
this because I think this is so
important that's for robotics to get out
there he's online machine shops I think
if you guys can dream up new consumer
applications and we can work together
that we can drive down costs we can we
can solve really hard problems and
there's never been a more important time
for academia to team with industry and
other academics to to bring you in the
next wave of robots okay I think we're
really entering exciting era era
can see the enthusiasm that we have for
the future and for what computing can do
to improve our lives and give us better
ways to work to play to live and so I
please join us in this enthusiasm and
please join us in the Q&A let me start
the Q&A session by asking each one of
our panelists one question and I see
that their microphones in the aisles is
join us for with your questions
absitively I painted the service really
exciting for the future of the world
wide web with what we want what
technologies what new technologies might
be needed to to get through your dream
well so the common now the current state
grant your web don't we know the html5
is what's different about html5
compatible original web guy started 25
years ago is every web page instead it
is completely programmable and the power
that we're giving us became more ppi's
exists me guys so to the web page needs
that you will can program your web page
to energy to program community with and
with real-time communication web RTC you
could get to web pages or two versions
of the same webpage run by different
users talking to each other without
necessarily going through the server so
you can build new distributed
applications using PHP protocols across
the internet based on arms web and
technology so that
right now it's very happy about like you
excited and I imagine that will cause
people to be to build the exciting new
patterns on top of that we're on top of
the web and exciting things on the staff
Thank You Tube so I'm you're anywhere
view of the web you have articulated the
importance of privacy and that
interaction apollon theme in your dream
and his dream and so let me ask you
Andrew in terms of this multi-party your
call you have outlined graphs and is it
used today in what feels like we imagine
using those ideas well I mean parts of
it are certainly used today because it's
based upon idea that were pioneered by
some of the early photographers folks at
csail like ron rivest shopping or glass
of Sylvia McCauley these are giants in
the field and they pioneered a lot of
applications when you use a credit card
transaction online you're using part of
those kind of encryption methods secure
multi-party computation though where
you're allowing
dividuals to equip their data and then
share the encrypted data to be able to
compute with it that's really new and
part of the newness comes from the fact
that it's only been a few years ago that
we solve the problem with so-called
fully homomorphic encryption that's a
scary sounding word that simply means
that you can encrypt your private data
then give something that I cooked the
data and they can take that data and
compute certain statistics as if they
had the unencrypted data but no time to
make access the underlying data and you
can imagine the applications are huge
for example not just in financial
applications for healthcare imagine if
we could share all of our healthcare
data to figure out what truly causes
cancer or diabetes but without having to
disclose details about our own private
medical condition that's an example
where I think it'll transform society if
we know the technology up so so that's
was great and it was very exciting to
see your pool in your presentation the
collaboration between computer
scientists
and finance and I just wonder if you can
evaporate dissolute bit more on this
open past that Dave and people forward
into the next decade scientists and
economists come together to solve even
more important problems well you know
more and more I think computer science
is actually getting involved in a number
of economic transactions actually part
of that it's thanks to temporarily in
the Internet of course ecommerce now is
something that we all take for granted
so the idea between computer science
particularly mechanism design auction
theory and how you construct the better
of marketplaces or interactions is
really coming from before so I think
that over the question next few years
you can see even more powerful
algorithms that will ultimately allow us
to do a better job of allocating scarce
resources across lots of my needs so
anyone you're sol La Russa found before
you learn stand up I want to ask you a
question I'm I'm very excited about your
presentation because when I share the
dream of
coming so they have a lot of talk about
self-driving cars recently where else I
little wats coming to comment invisible
I actually think self-driving cars is a
perfect example right both where where
we need legislation to help so it makes
it easier for people to do the
experiments they need to do to make
self-driving cars a reality I also think
that you know so Google's got the most
visible self-driving car project but all
the major auto manufacturers have
self-driving car projects but these cars
are driving right now they're out there
doing meaningful things but they're only
driving in in small scenarios where they
have perfect maps and they really are
not they haven't solved the whole
problem so it's a perfect example of how
you can the robots are at a point today
where they can do meaningful work they
can- vector people's lives but there's
still really hard to problem waiting on
guard to feel these things in reality
Thank You Russ so please join the
conversation we have a first question
would you like to introduce yourself I'm
Alex Brazil thanks for great inspiration
of times and this bit louder Alex
programmer in Brazil my question is
around okay so forty percent of us have
access to the Internet after all after
all this time we're talking about robots
and
most of the data going around into it is
not human generated anymore so maybe you
guys come in a bit about the Internet of
Things and how if robots on the internet
would impact you know or maybe even
overlap the human access to it I think
the first graphic that I'll defer to tip
but there's actually a great panel
yesterday at Colorado School and daniela
brought packs of here you go so you get
it CCL have further for asking the
question to ask more questions and get
hats it's a nice nap
but really hard to get fined so there's
a great panel yesterday on cloud
robotics so Google is talking about
toddler positive and can go over from
Berkeley there's a dream in the field
that that a robot that has a look at all
and individual robot can only have so
many experience but it takes time to
have experiences get data you can have
many robots out there feeling all the
time they can share experience they can
learn from each other they can map the
world much much faster right they can
leverage the compute power of the
servers right so the probabilities of
thing is happening definitely and there
are humans too so bone later out there
people worried about purchasing because
they weren't about that anything about
that Mikey am excited about than being
about me for me the Cabal you think
about me used to me so if you know if
some of the marketing for something
makes them make some money out knowing
something about my detailed history they
I come they will get a certain amount of
limited value of knowing about my
demographic but if me that stated about
eat it's going to tell me whether I'm
going to get a heart attack when what
I'm going to die also know we're gonna
die sorry
oh there then the then that's more
exciting selling guns suggest so my fav
a patent law is the one the sort of the
runs on here and check my movement just
by listening accelerometer knows gives
me now back as far as October I've got
when I been running and walking sleeping
and so that's so including where it
being a previous office putting the
journal of my life I ran into that show
my house I can tell me quite a lot about
when I was in the house about how I was
moving engine turning lights on north
and adjusting the temperature depending
the point where certainly the house gets
far enough to know when I'm going to be
around there is after all list no it's
going to get close tonight and program
this too when I get within a certain
radius of our miles to make sure it's
good we won't happen for me it's a bit
by bit there's also ways in which i want
the this world data to know a lot about
me because the other stuff that it could
then do is it that I won't have to do
and I can move out a bit to be more
creative look at the title so what I'm
interested in personal education I'm
using power that was living for myself
as opposed to worrying about who else is
using it to the end of errors thanks so
I can just if I could just jump in I'm
also very excited about mine
so excited about how I think way I live
with my data don't take my data but he
the other time I wanted to add to what
to set him is that we are not developing
technologies to give people control over
to access into data and half and sell
around with these new computational
approaches to ensuring privacy it will
be very easy and very comfortable for
people to give their data or whatever
forces and greater good and personal
objectives that we have while at the
same time to ensure that the data is not
used where they feel important so
infected and pepsi sector is we are
starting a information privacy project
which is going to be a little thicker
group within a center within the map any
white so funny any signal hitter and
he's a great fun of accountable systems
putting the council systems it's a
government so they become which make
sure that people use accountable for the
way they used data thank you for your
question if there's a next question
hello my name's Anna day is complicated
really fascinating penalty and the only
question about the future some of the
limitations in hardware for robotics is
all too soon and there was really
examples of swarming
bird and and it seems like and a lot of
software to trying to recreate a logical
system said the future peace at neural
networks machine madison very cool stuff
like it was great and I think it seems
like people of latched on this idea
really matron software what about
hardware we got to in terms of
biological there's some great famous
examples of limiting hardware to the
point where if your robot doesn't work
at all we have every kinematic every
every joint every link every voters in
the same place as a biological
counterpart and you have a beautiful
beautiful robot that doesn't
so so I think the inspiration so it so
for instance it can take the wild cat
video from from Boston Dynamics it
doesn't have every link in the same
place that a cheetah robot would have a
real ink but it's centered mass moves
surprisingly the ground reaction forces
are surprisingly similar to what a cheat
over two runs so it's at that level of
abstraction where we take the governing
principles of biology but skew them
towards the hardware that we're good at
building so she actually has more
powerful available at the joints than
then added by event of the biological
cheetah and we should have super you
should be able to do better than animals
and a lot of patience but we have to
build the hardware differently so it's
not a permission to file inspiration
instead of biomimicry
access to information do you recommend
to be better to apply this policy and
maybe technology changes so it's it's
the internet or are there fundamental
changes that could happen to be internet
that changing playing field altogether a
two way better than I can I try you
instantly it should we be inventive you
inspect exactly no we can be vintage is
constantly vision is constantly awaiting
the event though there has been a huge
problem without ever trying to get
people rule on ipv6 for my be4 partly
because it will step change but HTTP for
example is being continually another
yellow be quite a step change for this
EP 2 which is very much we thought much
more real-time binary protocol but HTTP
is in changing to fight english edition
of you Heather's it's been tweaking so
in a way it's really want to preserve
the existing structure to Britain old is
not going to be some dramatic change and
protocols we were going to get privacy
or something well we can yes moving to
lots of encryption but the encryption is
largely there so you should be using
HTTPS no validation see using SSL i use
PGP hang up in the hands up anybody use
the peach we use a pgp encryption on an
email a few getting their personal
thousand extra does and you don't ask
them about an asterisk because nobody do
we need to do is to use the stuff the
which is already there like Eugenie make
it much more easy for normal people to
use the location prior to PG
particularly pgp but you know in order
to resist the two example governments do
your own thing we have to work on the
government's you have to know we have to
put pressure on them have changed roles
here to change set an establishment
non National Constitution the Bill of
Rights of engine and there's no quick
technical fix to the Latin intense big
spiral thank you let's take the next
question my name is Jeff and I'm Doug
channeling off that a little bit
considering that it's taking 25 years to
get this current state of infrastructure
where you see things coming together
sort of an apple air to left mean
there's a ability to get to Port Caynn
things like that and we'd be reliant on
total companies to provide the service
with so many municipalities not being
able to you know ray down the pipe for
fiber etc okay so that's a very big
question we leave around two telephone
companies is really important but every
lyric internet episode connectivity down
content there that there are independent
mark markets and also independent from
the device lab so I can buy off the
device in one place I can completely
separate to choose my antenna client to
at the end choose which movies i watch
it with shoes either so separate keeping
those separate keeping each market so it
is a really competitive market is
important the last mile which you
mentioned which will be me stuck with
foie gras and cuellar town where I live
the electricity company is just going
into internet provision so what so that
so because it wasn't enough people
thought
competition in the phone company's
delivering in sent over last night the
other companies can get into so large a
large nameless intent companies and
search companies for example even can
get into it providing internet alright
so I think it's really important that we
don't think that we have to rely on
doing the existing tub tell codes for
supplying arms and port with the
challenge by all kinds of new business
models and you come in as every stage
can you see that changing changing Joyce
here I see the whole I I can see it can
make change in lots of different ways
and how it changes that to us is not
clear how it works please alright next
question if you had so much can you
describe a bit about that future far as
the type of nature job to exist the
future where robots become well and
truly ubiquitous develop it so I had to
maybe I'll again Danielle's also our
bosses let me let her kill the person so
we're very excited about working on
generation robots that will help people
in manufacturing and that will bring
manufacturing back in the US and we
imagine a world where workers will be
able to synthesize the robot for any
task using using computational tools and
easy interfaces the kind of level
walking cost if you will where instead
of printing your poster you will be
printing the robot to solve that
particular task on the mat at the time
when when you need a task but the robot
that cannot be fully control of the
factory people will still be in charge
the robots will be available to help
people and in my dream I would like to I
would like to see manufacturing
environment where we change from design
requests and fabricated in China to
design the u.s. customized at home in
your living room by yourself and fabric
I totally agree so in the first robot
revolution happened right around the
1980s where the Boomer robots came out
and then revolutionized factory robotics
right and if you look at the automotive
industry just before that happened and
just happen happen they were actually we
were producing basically after five or
ten years we were producing twice as
many cars but we are also employing
fifteen percent more people to make
those cars to work right so so every
time we've added a huge technology it's
been good for people it's been good for
jobs the challenge is going to be
educating people so that they can work
with the robots and the next level of
technology leap you have to work right
into the education system we have to
teach people computer science and
robotics when they're young and the you
know so Dean came in the first robotics
team is here at South by Southwest that
I just think this is so important for
the future to make this transition
happen thank you for that question next
next question hi good morning I have a
follow-up question on that and then a
question on Internet policy it's my
question on on the previous question was
do you see that as we started using
technology
driverless cars are introducing
technology like fabulous cars you can
receive for the taxi industry might
become quickly obsolete because that
happens how do you see markets were you
know for manual labor or entry-level
jobs will be affected by robotics and
how that might change I think you're
right that's a tough question i think
people's jobs will ultimately change
right but i think in the in the short
term it's important for us to embrace
technology make policy so that people
can explore this technology and educate
people so they can make the transition
but i think i think some jobs i mean
will will will inevitably change you
know I think self-driving cars are going
to take time but it's going to take all
they're not as close as as it might feel
watching YouTube but I hope that I'll be
reading a book next time I'm in a good
when I had a car in 20 years instead of
the son of being stressed out by the
wheel can I just jump into it to be
emphasized that yeah the jobs will not
change you the flip
they don't change instantly it will take
some time and so the question is how do
we retrain to go along with this
transition and hopefully during this
transition the jobs will become more
exciting and more interesting for all of
us just like what we experience that
with the agricultural revolution and
excellent yeah all that means if the
worthwhile thinking as a community and
how can we Institute training for people
were just entering the job market on how
they can move on from a market that
perhaps being replaced by new technology
and help them transition so that's a
that's a good question and here is a
dream what if every high school kids in
this country learned how to program in
high school not really cool yes yes I'm
thinking of that it's just as a little
just reading and arithmetic right again
it's not not just because we need more
programmers but because we need the
people who are lawyers and politicians
to know about a program or so that they
can understand what's possible with
technology the 21st century I believe
that programming is as important as we
being writing and calculates and women
yes yes which and work for lawyers as
well but to have a vision of technology
and as a manager as well I think it's
really important for managers also
understand technology if they're working
for technology Music keep yes yes all
right so my whole question is when you
join the battle okay we have time
and i work at you hi thank you very much
grateful so to Professor low you know
touch this subject little bit with the
financial data but my question is do you
think we can actually make a balance
between censorship and privacy and
sometimes that they can click so anywho
should do this you know like we should
we did at agency or you know media to do
this to make this balance also I think
that's a very important question that
you raised and I was actually gonna
bring it up when Tim was talking a bit
about data is on the internet all about
him I think that there's a lot of
benefits to having all your data out
there but your question really is about
potential costs and let me give you one
example in the telling you look I think
we feel about it if I were an insurance
company I would love to get that data
that tim has on his appt with his
accelerometer because I'd like to know
how fast he drives I'd like to know
where he goes I'd like to know what his
health condition is because once I find
out all the information I may decide to
refuse to ensure it because he's not a
good this in a way but and this is the
problem it's that when your data is out
there it can be used in ways that are
unanticipated and this is why I think
Tim's point about new legislation so
critical we don't have legislation to
protect our privacy and to prevent the
misuse of data because frankly when the
founders of our country work framing the
Constitution they didn't really
understand the notion of data and
privacy so i think that with better
legislation and legislation was going to
have to come from the people you're
going to have to write your Congressman
to say this is an important issue we
want you to be at the front of it and
not back I think that that's going to be
a critical part of what's going to
happen over the next five to ten years
so you think in someone should be able
to sense of data we stop there because
it's you know why I sounds pricey I'd
[ __ ] do that censorship is very
different from preserving privacy I
think this has to do with individual
rights in other words you have the right
not to share your data with me but
nobody should have the right to live in
our fake speech those are two very
different things and I think that right
now the law does not reflect that
distinction and we need to have better
legislation few of those issues it
features thank you for that question
were officially out of time so let me
suggest that those of you who haven't
added
so join us at the podium and before that
looks like the speakers